okay I'm going to talk to you about the
nitrogen cycle which is pretty much just
for hire students so let me show you how
it works now the nitrogen cycle just
shows us how nitrogen is moved
throughout different stores on earth
nitrogen is never created or destroyed
it's just move from one place or one
store to the other so I'm going to show
you how it's moved around and I'm also
going to show you about the four
different types of bacteria they're
involved in the nitrogen cycle as well
so I think it's best just to go step by
step so in the atmosphere the 78% of our
atmosphere is comprised of nitrogen now
unlike the carbon cycle where there's
just one thing that removes carbon from
the atmosphere there's several things
there's three things in fact three
different places where nitrogen is
remove from the atmosphere so we're
going to be introduced to our first type
of bacteria so our first type of
bacteria is called nitrogen fixing
bacteria so whenever we have nitrogen
fixing the word fixing means removing
nitrogen from the atmosphere so we're
taking it from the atmosphere and we
have nitrogen fixing bacteria which are
in the soil and we also have nitrogen
fixing bacteria which are in the roots
of these plants so there's our first
type of bacteria we need to know about
okay nitrogen fixing bacteria so there's
another way in another exciting way that
night did you get to move the atmosphere
during lightning so lightning provides
so much energy provides so much energy
that the nitrogen the air reacts with
the oxygen in the air so oxygen
comprises 21% of the Earth's atmosphere
so when we have a huge flash of
lightning like this it provides enough
energy for the nitrogen to react with
the oxygen to produce nitrates okay so
notice how there's three different three
different kind of routes for nitrogen to
be removed from the atmosphere
two of which would buy new
nitrogen-fixing bacteria in different
places so these nitrates let's think
about what can happen to them they could
be taken up by the plants through the
plants roots because nitrates actually
allow or help plants to grow so that's
again how the nitrogen is moved from
here so here again the whole cycle is
shown how nitrogen moves around now next
up let's think about where it can go
from the plant now I've done it
drawing it as a tree here but this could
just be any any plans at all okay now
here is my beautiful drawing of an
animal okay
so I can see here that by eating this
plant by eating this plan the nitrogen
has been transferred from the plan into
this animal here okay so what happens
next now we can think about what could
happen to these these things here so the
animals and the plants can die and they
can decompose and they produce when they
decompose they produces nasty substance
called ammonia so ammonia so what breaks
them down now we're going to be
introduced to our next type of bacteria
which is called d come poses
now what decomposes do is they
decomposes allow plants and animals to
be broken down into ammonia ammonia so
they break things down they allow things
to decompose so we've now got this
ammonia what can happen to that ammonia
okay we're going to introduce you to the
third type of bacteria we need to know
about which is called nitrifying
bacteria okay so what nitrifying
bacteria does if it converts ammonia
into nitrates think of the term
nitrifying making nitrates so again we
can see the transition from the night of
the nitrogen from ammonia to nitrate
with us third type of bacteria so we
have nearly finished
the only thing at the moment we can see
if there's nothing at all at the moment
which is returning any nitrogen to the
atmosphere so our last type of bacteria
we need to know about is D nitrifying
bacteria so it D nitrifiers now the idea
of that is we start off with a nitrate
and because we denature if we have d
nitrifying bacteria we no longer have
nitrates and this returns the nitrogen
into the atmosphere notice how there's
only one thing that's returning the
nitrogen to the atmosphere so finally
let's have a quick recap because we need
to know about the four different types
of bacteria so type number one is uh
nitrogen-fixing bacteria that we find in
the soil and we also find in the
flatteries number two are our decomposes
so remember these help to break down
dead plants and dead animals and in fact
urea as well so waste products from
these as well
into ammonia number three a third type
of bacteria is nitrifying bacteria what
nitrifying bacteria do is they turn
ammonia into nitrate think of nitrifying
making nitrates and a final type number
four Rd nitrifying bacteria returns the
night returns nitrogen to the atmosphere
by one yeah by from nitrates to the
atmosphere D nitrifying bacteria so the
best way to learn this is just to keep
drawing it and practicing it and make
sure you just think one step at a time
how do I get around remember there's
three different things that remove
nitrogen from the atmosphere only one
that returns nitrogen to the atmosphere
and there's four types of bacteria
thank you